for these goals are in the hundreds of
thousands then we process this
information on one outcome Y and a large
number of possible exploratory variables
X trying to find which of these genetic
laws I have information about the
possible value of the outcome to keep in
mind from the statistical point of view
is the fact that there is a fair amount
of dependence between the different
features um even though only at the
local level so features that are sitting
together in the genome tend to be
dependent and people that features that
are far apart tend to be independent and
it's also to important to keep in mind
that maybe what are really the causal
mechanistic variant that effect the
trait might not be actually genotyped or
measured um and we need to be able to
detect their effect through nearby
variant the standard way in which these
data set are analyzed it's fairly simple
even though the particular variance I'll
give you it's a little bit cartoonish um
what's typically done is that we March
through the genum one variant at a time
and um we declare a variant null if if
it's independent from the phenotype so
really for each of these snip single
nucleotype polymorphisms that um are
genotyped in the genome we fit a linear
model that it's univariate and we test
the hypothesis that the coefficient of
dis it's equal to zero um we also
because we are doing this a large number
of times we need to put in place some U
method for controlling multiplicity and
we use the familywise error rates so we
try to control control the familywise
error rate at the level
05 um I told you this is a cartoonish
version because we have often a
population structure individuals that
are more related to each other than
others we use mixed models rather than
this simple model um but it still
remains true that this is not a model
that describe our understanding of the
trade because the traits we are
interested to study in genomewide
association studies are what we called
complex traits that is those that we
think are influenced by a large number
of variants across the genome so because
we have um used these fairly simple
models there are some limitations a
major one is that not all the signal is
captured so um in early studies to which
this picture refers to what you see is
what portion of all of these traits we
could explain in a data set represented
by the total length of the bars and the
red portion of the bars is the part that
we could explain with genetic variant
now this is an old plot that dates back
to 2009 since then we have dramatically
increased the sample size of these
studies and this has contribut to
increase uh the power and the proportion
of variance explained though it's still
fairly contained um and to the point
that when we want to actually use
genetic data to predict the risk of
individuals or to predict the phenotypes
they might have we AB the approach that
I have just described and we use models
that include many more Snips than the
one we have
selected another limitation is that this
univariate model lead to result that are
difficult to explain what you have in
the top here it's a a picture of a small
area on chromosome 12 I believe relative
to height um and on the xaxis you have
positions of the Snips each dot
correspond to one of these polymorphis
and on on the Y AIS you have minus log
10 of the P values now you can see the P
values are very very small this is in a
very large study um but what you can see
is that there are very many um Snips in
the same neighborhood that have very
small P values and that's because all of
these nips are fairly dependent to each
other and when we use these univarate
models um there might be one that it's
really responsible for the phenotype but
all the other ones become guilty
associations and it's impossible to
distinguish which one is more important
than others using univariate models is
also impossible to count really how many
independent signals I have here and so
um what geneticists do is that after
they have these results they try to
create clusters of these nips that in
this case are called clumps trying to
identify which groups of snips dependent
among the others among each other can be
identified and these different clumps
here are colored with different colors
and then Locus by Locus we resort to
multivariant models to carry out what is
called Fine mapping that tries to
disambiguate the role of difference
variants um so now this is a seminar you
this year the focus of this seminar is
on AI and you know AI right now it's
really intended as uh deep
learning and it's natural to ask why if
we have these rich data sets we don't
use more modern machine learning or deep
learning methods and you know part of it
is inertia in a field it always takes a
while to introduce new methodology but a
big component of this is the fact that
in this field we really feel the need to
control false positive discoveries the
goal is not to predict a phenotype from
the genetic data in fact if you think
about it predic a phenotype it's in many
cases fairly useless like you I don't
need to predict how tall you are I can
just measure you I do not need to
predict what is your cholesterol level
from your genetic data I can just
measure your cholesterol level what we
want to do with this genom Association
studies it's to identify precisely which
portion of the genome have something to
say about the phenotype because that one
will point us to biological pathway
underlining these traits and if we know
biological pathways we have
possibilities of developing drug targets
for example so our Focus here it's
really on understanding on the science
not so much on the prediction task and
for um this to be possible we need to be
able to
control the false positive that are made
and to identify location precisely
another element that just that can be
considered as a way to understand why we
stick to this simple univariate model is
the fact that we do need to be able to
handle dependent observations um and we
have consideration of privacy so
sometimes actually people do not want to
use the entire data but only summary
statistics so what I want to talk to you
about it's an alternative approach that
we have been um developing um over
almost the last 10 years um that
suggests that rather than using these
simple um univariate statistics we
really want to deploy the power of
machine learning deep learning AI if you
want to to understand what are all the
signatures that um genetic variance um
what is the genetic signature of
different traits but we do want to have
discoveries that are distinct and
coherent that comprehensively describe
all the portion of the genome that are
relevant for a trait and that have false
Discovery rate control guarantee
even if the data comes from family or
structural
populations and um there's two
fundamental ingredients of this
alternative approach one is the shift
from um marginal testing to conditional
testing and what I mean with this is
that we are going to say that we
discover a snip um only if we can reject
the hypothesis that snip J it's
independent from trait y conditionally
on the rest of the genome that is we are
not interested in discovering marginal
association between a snip and a trait
but we are only interested in
discovering those Snips that have
something to tell me about the trait on
top of what the rest of the genome tells
me this is interesting because it
tomatically controls for the effect of
distant Losi it avoids a duplication of
signals due to correlated close variance
which in genetics we call linkage
disequilibrium and which is what I try
to illustrate with this plot with
multiple color dots and it carries out
what in genetic is called f mapping
automatically so that's the first
ingredient the second ingredient needs
to move from the desire to control
familywise error rate to the desire to
control false Discovery rate um this is
I find much more appropriate for the
type of Investigations related to
complex traits when we do complex traits
we are thinking oh we need to discover
the hundreds
thousands tens of thousand positions in
the genome that are important for these
traits now if you are out to disc
discover to make thousands of
discoveries is really not too bad of a
deal if you make one false one what you
really want to do is to control the
proportion of false discoveries and the
false Discovery rate captures this much
better so what I'm going to do today
hopefully is to give you a basic idea of
what's behind this alter alternative
approach and then focus on the specific
challenge of multi-resolution analysis
in genom wide Association studies and um
illustrate how evalues can help us
selectively um adaptively select the
optimal
resolution so first let's start with the
very basic idea and uh let me try to
tell you what is the basic underlying
challenge so we want to use machine
learning method and uh let's just pick
one simple one um just the Lum and we
say we are going you know we cannot just
do multivariant regression in the case
of genom Association studies we have
more um explanatory variable than um
observation so we might want to do um
some regularized version of it like theu
and we know that theu tends to put lots
of coefficients the coefficients of lots
of variables to zero um so we could say
well well I might use the lasso to try
to fit a model that explains the
phenotype in terms of genetic variance
um and I want to say I'm going to
consider as important the genetic
variance whose coefficient is not set to
zero and um while the this audience
might very well know this let me just
emphasize that unfortunately while the
lassu guarantees if it is well tuned
good predictive properties it really
doesn't give us any guarantees about the
appropriateness of this selection so
what I have here it's a very small
simulation studies where I've used 500
there are 500 explanatory variables and
I have generated a trait and then I have
run the lassu um with one particular
value of Lambda um to then estimates the
coefficients of all of these variables
and in the plot you have on the x- axis
the variables simply in order and on the
y axis the value of the absolute value
of the fitted lassu coefficient which we
can take as a measure of feature
importance then the dots you see are in
two colors the red dots corresponds to
the variables that were effectively used
to generate the phenotype and the blue
dots to the variables that were not used
and you can see that the lassu does a
good job picking out the important
variables in the sense that high value
of the lastu coefficients are
corresponding to uh red
dots and does it a good job to identify
the lots of the other variables are not
important there is a lot of variables
whose coefficients are put to zero
however if I were to say I'm going to
select as important all the variable
whose absolute value of the coefficient
estimated by the lasu is larger than
zero I would have a false Discovery
proportion of
70% so what is challenging here is to
find where is the right TR threshold to
use um so I'm going to be willing to
lose some important discoveries but I
don't want to make too many false one
where would I put a cutout threshold and
um one idea that um we can um think of
playing with is to say let's use dumi
variable so let's ex expand the set of
uh features that we are analyzing with
another set of features that replicate
characteristics of these original
features
but are known to be unrelated to the
outcome so what I could do is to monitor
what the lassu does for these features
that I know to be unrelated and use this
as a le as a stick to decide what I
should use as cut off to declare
important
values um in this picture here what I
have done is to create 500 dummy
variables that are gaussian variant that
have the same variance Co Varian
structure of the original features and
the feature importance statistics in
terms of absolute value of the lassu
coefficients of these variables it's
represented with the dark blue dots now
you can see that the lassu recognizes
that these variables are not important
but these dark blue dots really don't
mimic the pale blue dots distribution so
I cannot really use this to decide what
is an appropriate thresold another way
of making dummy variables that we could
think about is to use permutation so I
could take my original data set permute
the labels so I get a set of dami
variables that has exactly the same
distribution as my original features and
this is the results of what happens if I
do the same exercise again theu
recognizes that these permuted features
are not important but at the same time
they have a very different
distribution now there is another
another type of dumi variable called
knockoffs that was introduced by barar
and candes in
2015 and um this is what happens if I do
the same exercise now you can see that
the dark blue dots very much have the
same distribution as the pale blue one
so I can use them to guide my selection
of what is an appropriate threshold so
what are these knockoff dummies
variables um let me give you one
particular recipe um that as that is the
one that we use in genomewide
association studies um the idea is that
we think that our observation features
and uh phenotypes are IID sample from a
distribution we make a two two different
Assumption of this distribution we
assume that we know the distribution of
the features exess but we make no
assumption whatsoever on how the outcome
why it's connected to the feature X's
these no cost are um carefully
constructed negative controls um that
are in fact from the statistical
Viewpoint indistinguishable from X so
we're going to use the notation XA to
indicate these knockoffs and what I mean
with statistically indistinguishable is
that if I take the joint distribution of
the original variable and the
knof and I swap any variable with its
knockoff I obtain another Vector that
has the same distribution so in the
examples here I could swap for variable
two and three the original variable with
the knock off and this will have the
same distribution and then they are of
course independent from y now this
allows us to see for example why
permutations are not a good negative
control suppose that X1 is an important
variable and X2 it's a no one but assume
that they are correlated so in the
original data set X 2 can act as a proxy
for X1 now suppose we create permutated
version of my variables then X1 and X2
permute will have the same distribution
of X1 and X2 so the correlation between
X1 and X2 is the same as the correlation
between X1 permute and X2 per mute and
the correlation of X1 permuted and Y and
X2 permuted and Y it's obviously zero it
is also true however that the
correlation between X2 per mute and X1
is zero because I have completely
created a new data set and that means
that in my um permuted data set X2
permute does not capture the fact that
the original X2 gets a lift from X1
instead the knockoffs are constructed so
that the correlation between X2 knockoff
and X1 is the same as the correlation
between X2 and
X1 so how to use knof well first first
of all you have to construct these
knockoffs and there is um what I
mentioned here it's a literature about
how to construct knockoffs for genetic
data um you might be interested to know
that we can also leverage deep learning
to construct knockof so in fact mesia
and Yan Romano has have a paper called
Deep knockof that describes that and
then once you construct the noof you
have to use them to make this selection
I'm not going to cover too much how to
construct the cost for gas let me uh for
genetic data let me just emphasize that
it is a case where it is a really this
is a really well posed problem because
we know a lot about the distribution of
genotypes we have a lot of data and
there are really reasonably good model
for um their distribution that are
routinely used um say to impute
genotype and uh this is a plot from one
of the latest paper by Mato CIA on pnas
uh describing how these knockoffs allow
us to if you look at the original data
and the knockoff of these data um they
recapitulate um the dependency and the
cross dependencies um that are necessary
for the KN of construction but they are
also able to recapitulate the level of
relatedness between individuals in a
sample and the different population
structure I realize that this is very
fast be happy to ask question answer
questions afterwards I just want to give
you an overview so that there is some
level of completeness um on what we're
getting
at now suppose you have constructed
these knockoffs then what do you do you
do exactly what I sort of described in
the terms of the lasso you put your
original data and the knockoff into a
method that you're going to use to
determine feature important statistics
and so we can really keep in mind as a
feuture important statistics the
absolute value of the estimated L
coefficient ient and then you are going
to combine the signal coming from your
original variable and your knockoffs in
one information in one knock of score
for each of the variables and these
knock of scores has to be such that the
way you combine the data is that if you
flip the role of the original variable
then then knock off you change the sign
what we can think of is that you simply
take the difference between the absolute
value that the variable the original
variable has in the lassu coefficient
minus the estimated absolute value of
the coefficient for the knockoff value
so these are are what we call knockoff
scores and um their characteristics is
that a large W says that the variable in
question appears to be important a
negative value says that the knockoff
for that variable seems to be more
important than the original variable so
this problem probably it's not a
variable that it's really important now
crucially the wjs for the no variables
are symmetrically distributed and
conditionally on their absolute value
the signs of KN of scores corresponding
to null hypothesis are IID coin fly so
the idea of the KN of filter is that we
are going to use these W's to guide our
selection and what we're going to do we
are going to come up with an estimate of
the false Discovery proportion
Associated to any selection and select
the N the maximal number of variables
compatible with keeping this estimate of
the false Discovery proportion below a
certain value Q now what is the estimate
of the false Discovery proportion um say
that we I'm going to look at a threshold
T and say I consider rejecting all the
null hypothesis relative to the
variables that have a knockof score
larger than
T so this is my value T and I'm plotting
um on the x-axis the absolute value of
the KN of score and then telling you if
it is a plus or a minus so you would
select only variables with knock of
score it's larger than T um and so this
ones would be the all the variables with
the plus sign here
you're going to estimate as number of
false discoveries in this set you're
going to use the count of how many
variables have an absolute value W
larger than T but have negative numbers
so you will estimate the total number of
false rejection in this case as one and
your total number of rejections would be
five so you can take the ratio between
these two values and get a valid
estimate of fdp and that is what is
going going to drive your
selections so let me tell you what
happens when you apply these two genome
wide Association studies as I hinted it
is quite feasible to construct knockoffs
um but let's get back to what is the
null hypothesis that we test we said we
are interested in testing this
conditional null that says I want to
discover variable X size that are
independent from my f type given the
rest of the genome and I said this is
great because um it avoids making
repetitive discoveries that I do not
know how to interpret however there is a
little catch suppose that the dependency
between XI and its neighbors it's quite
High then it becomes a tall order to be
able to identify that XI has something
more to tell me about why than what the
neighbors do and let's let's look at
what happens this in terms how that it's
true in the case of knockoffs so we're
going to just use this Kon
representation for two variables and use
the angle between these two vectors to
represent the correlation between these
two variables so say that I have
variable XJ and XK and I need to
construct a knockoff for
XJ the requirement is that the
correlation between the knockof of XJ
and X K it's the same as the correlation
between XJ and XK so one easy way of
satisfying this requirement is to say
well I take as knock off of XJ the same
thing as XJ so in this case XJ Tilda
it's exactly equal to XJ now that you
know how we're going to use this KN off
and you know that we're going to compare
the coefficient that XJ tlda is going to
have in the lassu with the coefficient
of XJ you realize quickly that this one
will give you zero power because XJ is
identical to its
knockof so to maximize your power what
you want to do is to place this Vector
representing XJ Tilda as far away as
possible from XJ while keeping the angle
with XK the same so that's what I'm
doing here I'm taking the vector on the
opposite direction the angle between XJ
till and XK is the same as the angle
between XK and X J but I have lower
correlation between XJ and XJ TAA now
unfortunately when I have variables that
are very tightly correlated it becomes
this stct it's not sufficient so I'll do
the same here but it's still true that
XJ tlda it's highly correlated with XJ
what this is telling us is that it's
hard to distinguish highly correlated
predictors now you know of course that
this is not a problem specific of
knockoff it's a problem that it's common
to to any multivariat models and um a
common solution that it's adopted for
this one is to say well we're going to
group variables and say variables that
are tightly correlated we're going to
consider them as part of the same set we
might choose a representative or you
know something of along this line and we
can do the same with knockoff so instead
of constructing knockoff for individual
level hypothesis we can construct KN
offs for group hypothesis that are very
much like the original no course but we
relax the changeability criteria and to
stick to um the cartoon representation
what this relaxation allows us to do is
to say I'm going to if I have two
variables X1 and
X2 um that are tightly correlated I'm
going to call them as part of one group
and I'm going to have only to preserve
the correlation of variables in this
group with variable outside that group
but I can move the
Vector I can construct a knoff for X1
and X2 jointly together so I can do this
move um place my two knockoffs farther
away from my original
ones so this means this is how about how
would you construct these group features
um and then of course if you you need to
come up with some uh feature important
sampling for the group and what you can
do for example is simply sum the values
of the absolute value of the estimate of
the beta coefficient in theu so what we
do in genomewide association studies is
that we take all of the Snips in the
genome we um evaluate their dependency
calculate the correlation between them
create a a hierarchical tree um that
puts together Snips that are highly
correlated earlier we um also typically
impose a constraint of
um agency meaning that we ask snip in
the same cluster to be sitting together
on the genome and then we can cut this
um tree at various levels to come up
with different resolutions groups for uh
the genome and then we can analyze this
using the
lasso um what you have here on these two
different rows are the results of
constructing knos with two different
different recipes um that are simply
leveraging models that have been
developed in genetics shap it and fast
pH um and what you have is histograms of
the um pairwise similarity of the
absolute value of the correlation
coefficient between each snip and each
knockoff varying um depending on the
size of the groups so when we construct
um noos for testing the single Snee
hypothesis you can see that there is is
a fair amount of them that have very
high correlation with their original
Snips so this one will correspond to
very low power as we construct groups
that have lower resolution we can solve
that problem and for example in these
larger groups you see actually there is
very low correlation between a snip and
it's
knockoff so when we put this together we
do a multi-resolution analysis of the
genome and this uh Chicago cloth are the
graphical displays that um we have used
to represent the results um let me spend
a little bit of time describing what
they are um on the x axis you have
position along the
genome and this what we're looking at
it's chromosome 12 um and in in this
area we have a zoom in in one particular
place in chromosome
12 along the Y AIS we represent
different level of resolutions so let's
look at the zoom in
panel the zoom in panel um if we start
from the bottom we see that what we see
is that we have a series of stacked
boxes on top of each other now each box
correspond to one hypothesis for for one
group for which we could reject the null
hypothesis so if I have a box here it
tells me that um I was able to reject
the n hesis that there is something in
this area of the genome that tells me
something about the phenotyping question
that in this case is height on top of
what the rest of the genome tells me so
I know that there is something unique in
this area that it's important for my
phenotype and what you have here below
is the dendogram that was used to
construct these blocks and you can see
that uh what I have emphasized in uh
light blue it's the the level of
resolution corresponding to these blocks
that you have constructed now as we move
upwards on the Y AIS you have different
level of resolutions you see the boxes
here are sometimes smaller and if we
represent if we depict a box here it
says well in this case I was able to
narrow down the signal and I was able to
see not only there is something here but
there is something in this smaller area
that tells me something about height on
top of the rest of the genome and you
can see that in some cases um the
resolution can become fairly um precise
in this case for example we can reject
the hypothesis that this snip here has
nothing to tell me about height on top
of the rest of the
genome so at each resolution this
hypothesis these discoveries are
distinct so I know that there is
something going on here and something
going on here and something going on
here that are distinct which is quite
different from the mess that you have
with univariate analysis where you
really know that there is a signal
around here but not exactly too much now
while I do think this is quite nice um
when you look at these plots what you
want to do as a geneticist is to say
well um let me focus on the most precise
discoveries that we have made so this is
a cartoon representation because these
are my discoveries really what I want to
say is that well I am not interested in
the fact that you have discovered all of
this B big block um at this low level of
resolution for this area you are able to
narrow it down to this block here this
block here and so on and in these two
cases I was able to narrow it down very
much so as a geneticist I want to look
at these most precise discoveries that I
have made in once in each
location and unfortunately um if you
simply go ahead and select these most
precise discoveries you do not have
false Discovery rate control
guarantee and so um maybe this one uh
it's um a more explicit cartoon version
of it um uh to bring home the point um
and what I'm trying to represent here is
what we can call a multi resolution
family of hypothesis so what I'm
thinking in this particular case is that
I have an underlying signal represented
by these dots and um the red dots
represent some you know true non all um
and then in in instead of necessarily
testing um hypothesis Associated to the
resolution of the signal I consider
different level of resolution so I have
at this level one this level three this
hypothesis that corresponds to a group
so h13 would be um non null if any of
the dots underlying h13 is nonnull and
then you I have short smaller group up
and smaller group UPS yet and in this
plot um false ns are indicated in red
and imagine the rejections are shaded in
blue and the most specific rejections at
each resolu uh most specific rejections
for each signal are indicated with this
um thick blow
conts so now what we can see is
that if I now uh count false Discovery
proportion the overall false Discovery
proportion is 2 over 10 and then I can
look at the false Discovery proportion
at this resolution at resolution two or
at resolution three um and um you have
the numbers on the slides what is
interesting is that if I look at the
false Discovery proportion of the most
specific um nonredundant precise
Discovery this is fairly high so um
the the goal of the work that uh Paul
Gamblin um really LED is to come up with
a strategy that allows us to select this
most specific uh discoveries um while
keeping FDR control and um she was able
to do it leveraging two um recent
Innovation one is a formulation of this
problem given by uh Spectre and Johnson
um that look at this problem from the
basian perspective but what they
introduce also it's a criteria to
describe uh the problem so
um let me just go through this notation
because we'll um see it
again we think that we have this
multi-resolution family of hypothesis
corresponding to collection of groups
defined starting from the P individual
hypothesis each hypothesis has a weight
that identifies how valuable its
rejection is and if what we have in mind
is that most specific discoveries are
the most valuable one we can imagine to
take as a way
um the inverse of the size of the group
then we're going to use this indicator X
a01 to say zero if the hypothesis is not
rejected and one if the hypothesis is
rejected and what our Google can be
thought of is that we want to maximize
this weighted power that we want to
maximize the weighted number of
discoveries while we control the false
Discovery rate and while while we make
non-redundant ones now uh seor and
Johnson gave a solution for this problem
in the context of basian analysis we're
not we are interested in looking at the
problem from a um frequeny Viewpoint and
to solve this um we were able to
leverage the concept of evalue and um I
am keeping an eye on time and realize
that um we don't have h a lot of time
left so um my apology if I'm breezing
through this but um EV values can be
considered as something equivalent to P
values they are random variables that
have specific distributional property
under the n and under the N for E value
we simply ask that their expectation is
smaller than equal than one instead for
P value we ask that the probability with
which A P value is smaller than Alpha
under the null has to be small smaller
than equal than
Alpha now from this property alone you
can see that e values are going to be
easier to handle expectation it's much
more friendly than statement on the um
cumulative generating function and what
we're going to do is to leverage these
easier calculus of EV values in
particular um for Ev values you can see
that any multiple comparison procedures
that has the proper of being
self-consistent it's guaranteed to
control false Discovery rate
self-consistency is a property that was
introduced in the context of FDR control
by Blanchard andan and it's also
relevant for p values but um when you
look at P values you need to say well
the property has to be self-consistent
and then I need to have some specific
assumption on the distribution of the P
values instead for Ev values if you can
assure that your selections are
self-consistent um you automatically get
FDR control and just to make ourselves
familiar with what self-consistency may
means um we can just recall that
self-consistency is the property that P
values have in a bamini hotb procedure
so the P values of any rejected
hypothesis are going to be smaller than
Alpha times K the number of rejected
hypothesis so far over the total number
of hypothesis tested so you can um flip
it around keeping in mind that if you
have an e value one / e it's a P value
and say well so I if I have e values I
could construct P values then do bamin
hurg on these P values this will give
you a procedure that controls FDR for Ev
values and it gives you the idea of what
self consistency are so let me me just
State what is this uh solution for um
our problem we have a multi resolution
family of hypothesis corresponding to a
collection of groups for each hypothesis
we have an e value and a weight and um
we have a certain level of FDR control
so what we're going to do is to
solve a linear program that says you're
going to maximize the total number of
weighted discoveries so again this WS
represent the value we associate to each
Discovery and X tells if the if a it's
if an hypothesis has been rejected or
not we are going to impose that these
discoveries are not redundant the way we
are going to do this is to go back to
the P or individual variable that are
underlying this group hypothesis and we
are going to say each individual
variable can be part of a dis discovered
hypothesis only once so if I look at all
the groups that contain variable J and
count how many of them have been
discovered only one can be discovered so
I simply impose non redundancy and then
I impose self-consistency now you um
there are very many constraints here
because we are putting a constraint for
every single um hypothesis in the
scenery um and it might not be immediate
evident that this is cell consistency
but for the hypothesis for which XA is
zero there's no constraint here this is
trivially satisfied because e values are
positive and for the hypothesis where XA
is X a one that is the hypothesis
rejected this is precisely
self-consistency
now the last ingredient I have to give
you to arrive to our solution is to
notice that the knockoff procedure can
actually be written in terms of evalue
this one is the knockoff filter um as we
have described before and um Ren and
barber in a beautiful paper that came
out last year described how we can
Define e Valu starting from these
knockoff scores and if we apply an um
the equivalent of BH to these EV values
we get a rejection set that it's exactly
the same as the knockof filter so what
does this allow us to do it allows us to
take all of the different analysis of
different resolutions that we have made
of the genome and instead of analyzing
separate them separately using a no of
filter all of these analysis based on
knockoff can be used to define evalues
for these different hypothesis at
multiple resolutions and then we can
pass this evalue to the linear
programming procedure that I have just
described and obtain discoveries now I
this slide might not be very um
appealing to look at so let's just
quickly look at some uh simulation
results um where we compare the results
of this procedure that we called KP
knockoff um evalue linear programming
with um procedures that are just based
on the original knockoffs now um the
dash purple line represents the results
of uh the situation where you apply
knockoffs resolution by resolution and
then you select the most specific
discoveries and as you can see this does
not lead to FDR control instead K it's
this blue line and it nicely has FDR
control the pro the lines on the yellow
Spectrum represent the power and the
false Discovery rate of the knockoff
procedure resolution specific and they
of course control fdp and they can be
quite powerful um however this high
power for this um you see that this high
power It's associated with low
resolutions so if you stick yourself to
this low resolution hypothesis you can
never adaptively identify the signal
where it's present um instead you can
see that our the power of KP is very
much similar to the power of the outer
node while it controls
FDR uh let me give you some instead of
simulation some real data analysis this
is the analysis for a a phenotype
related to platelets in the UK B bank
which is a a big publicly available data
set and what you have here it's
resolution by resolution the number of
discoveries made by kelp the number of
discoveries that you would see a bad
resolution if you were to select outer
node of the resolution specific
analysis and these the discoveries of
the resolution specific analysis you can
see that the kelp and outer nodes make
the similar number of discoveries in
this case what is interesting is that um
with kelp you can make more very high
resolution discoveries than what you
would have made with the original not
offs and that's because in the original
knockoffs at high resolution you're just
comparing all of these very specific
hypothesis that are very high to reject
when you do help you're simultaneously
looking across many resolutions and so
because you make some rejections at the
low resolution level this gives you
extra power to make rejections at the
high resolution
levels this is a picture of how the
results look for height so we can
actually paint the entire genome and see
which regions have informations to give
us about height and this picture it's
valid in the sense that every region
that it's depicted gives you information
that it's different from what's in the
other regions it's you know there's no
confusion and um the resolution is as
precise as you can get so um concluding
um I hope I convince you that are there
are ways of analyzing J's data that
really can take advantage of the most
sophisticated machine learning methods I
have not been able to give you details
but there's much more work that has been
completed and ongoing to really oper
oper operationalize this program for the
analysis of genetic data so we can work
we have work about what does it mean to
replicate across population we can do
use using summary statistics but then
maybe abstracting a little bit from the
context of uh genetic Association
analysis um what do I think is the
message with respect to data science in
general I want to put the emphasis on
science in data
science I think science is about
expanding our knowledge and our
understanding and these genomewide
Association studies are good examples of
them what we want to do is to understand
what is the biology behind different
diseases um and the scient the data
science methods then that we use have to
be able to expand our knowledge and
understanding we cannot um just consider
ourselves satisfied if we have a machine
that does what we can do or what the
less smart or the less knowledgeable
among ask can do um we really need to
push the envelope and make new
discoveries with the guarantees that we
uh need as a community to be able to
trust them let me do the same thing that
Jack did at the beginning um this is our
data science at Stanford weaving data
science to the fabric of the university
is the slogan of the Stanford data
science initiative and um we currently
have position open in statistics
statistics in data science and biomedic
data science and I encourage you to
check them out and let me thank you for
your attention and for the opportunities
that activities like this that uh
connect us across the world through our
intellectual Endeavors give us um
to really develop a sense of a global
human community that is not as fractured
as um we unfortunately see to be uh
often thank you
gra I really really appreciate the way
you ended your talk and that we really
need to emphasize the science I liked
the comment that you had in the
beginning of your talk as well about why
not just go use machine learning let's
just go use deep learning and we'll let
the machines all figure it out but the
thing I think you really emphasize which
I I really am very appreciative of is
that we are scientists we want to test
hypotheses and that the machines they're
not going to know that right they are
going to be helpful tools to help us to
test those hypotheses but a deep
Learning System is just not going to be
able to do that for us and I think the
the the presentation that you've given
really helps to to drive uh that home uh
as you were talking and I know that
you're based at Stanford and I know that
you're very well connected with the uh
data science Community there and as you
were talking about the the genomewide
association type work that you do I was
curious if you have had the opportunity
to apply these methodologies to other
data sets which are large uh spacially
co-varying and again I'm thinking from
my own experience of human neuroimaging
where we collect a lot of Imaging data
that has spatial autocorrelation in it
um and we often make multiple multiple
multiple test you know testing multiple
hypotheses and we have a multiple
comparisons problem that is been
particularly vexing and I'm curious if
any of these methodologies uh you might
have gotten together with my good friend
Russ pldr for example to talk about how
to apply these methods yeah uh we have
done exactly that so I don't have um
results to show yet um but especially
now that we have solve this
multi-resolution
problem um we have started working in
the the context of um neuroimaging and
uh indeed uh Paula and I were in Ras
office um not long ago discussing
exactly which type of hypothesis we need
to make see what um the methodology is
of course fairly General but what it's
needed it's for you to be able to
generate these noost and um what I hope
I gave you a sense of is that I feel
very confident about the noost that we
generate for genetic data because we do
have a good representation of what is
the distribution of these alal of course
it's not going to be exact but you know
there's lots of reasons for us to be
confident about we do know the
distribution of x's I personally have
not worked very much in neuroimaging so
I didn't know how well we know the
distribution of the signals that we get
from neuroimaging and what are the
assumptions that we can uh reasonably
make um but uh it seems that you know
gastan random Fields is a place where to
start and that's really very much what
we are trying to do at the moment yes
the G Unum Fields theory has you know
from Pioneer Carl friston and others for
neuroimaging is is a great place to
start it kind of makes some assumptions
about or measurements and then tries to
incorporate the underlying smoothness of
the data um into your probabilistic
estimates but um this seems to go beyond
that which is actually really intriguing
looking at kind of a multi-resolution
kind of approach this reminds me of some
work that was done by the noted
statistician Keith Worley um gosh a
number of years ago looking at multiple
resolutions of neuroimaging data to try
and get more precise and testing
hypotheses at each level um so anyway
that there would be a really interesting
application of these methods and I I do
hope to see you uh pursue it one
question is do you have any um software
tool which might be available is there a
GitHub that you could point us to or
some other place where you know there
for those people who are interested and
struggling with gws related problems
they may want to take a look yes there
are um multiple places uh and you know I
should um have um them handy um do you
want me to try to put them in the chat
or do you want me to just call out um or
and send them to yeah if you want to say
call them out now and if you send them
to us we can make sure to kind of link
them in uh to where we have your talk
advertised so people prob EAS if I call
them out so one um Emmanuel candes group
has been um really developing a lot of
software for knockoffs so if you look at
Emanuel candes page and his software
page you'll see link to multiple of
these um the author of multiple of this
uh software has been Mato CIA so you can
also look at his page um he's now at USC
and finally we have a new
um set of software that it's already
available but it's going to be released
with some ffir we hope um author by
Benjamin to he's in my lab and um this
is in Julia uh so previous development
have been you know with r or p
interfaces and this one also has wrapper
for RN python but the code is all
written in Julia which gives us um
fairly good um computational
performances so there is a lot of
software actually that um can be
leverage so far it has not been super
easy for the aage geneticist to do that
in that it requires multiple steps and
uh some of the effort that uh Benjamin 2
has been doing is to really make it
plug-in play even for somebody um in the
genetic context but all of these
software actually allows you to apply
the net to whatever is the context of
your
interest sure that's really helpful
we're at our time so let me say thank
you again I really appreciated your talk
this was very intriguing I was not
really aware of knockoffs and evalues
and how they might relate to one another
but that's very exciting and given my
own work in neuroimaging I I I could see
a lot of promise for this obviously
stuff being done in in genomic uh
analysis is going to be very important
um I do some work with autism spectrum
disorder which is very heterogeneous the
the gene the genetics for it is still
kind of a mystery although we have some
candidates but perhaps a method like
this may be very important um so I'll be
looking into pursuing that too but in
the meantime thank you so much for
joining us and for sharing your work
this was really inspirational and I
really want to thank you um I want to
thank everybody who is joining us um on
YouTube and uh we will not be having a
um a a seminar next week in honor of the
US Thanksgiving holiday but uh we will
see you uh in two weeks hence and with
that everyone have a wonderful Friday
and uh we will uh see you next time
thank you again Kiara thank you